amazon is a global leader in the use of
artificial intelligence and robots now
first on CBS this morning
the online giant is revealing how it
plans to invest more than 700 million
dollars on its human workforce to
provide a hundred thousand US employees
with new skills for the digital age we
also got a first-hand look at the
company's newest fleet of robots that
work with humans to help get your
packages out for delivery CTM lead
national correspondent David beg no
spoke to an Amazon CEO David what stood
out to you well here's what we saw
robots are seemingly everywhere and will
only more become a part of our future
you know even here at CBS News some of
our cameras are operated robotically
with that wave of Workforce automation
comes concerns that robots are gonna
replace us take our jobs but Amazon
tells us qualified people are needed
more than ever when you go to this
125,000 square foot Amazon facility
right outside of Denver
it looks like robots are running the
show but behind these roughly 800
devices are skilled employees like
Nicole bear who manages the daily flow
of traffic as a floor control specialist
bear says more robots means higher
package volume and with that we need
more associates to process our volume
not less bear joined Amazon just a few
years ago she had been out of the
workforce for quite a while she credits
the company's employee programs for
helping to relaunch her career we
traveled to Amazon Seattle headquarters
to talk with its worldwide consumer CEO
Jeff Wilkie about how these programs are
going to work would you compare this to
going
University and two years of training
it's kind of like grad school and the
programs names feel collegiate like
machine learning University for on-site
training and Amazon technical academy
for software engineer roles as
technology changes work they have the
opportunity to advance in their career
and take advantage of those changes
right but you sound like your PR people
give me that give me the realistic
version right like what do you need your
employees to start doing with this
training creating great jobs means that
people can have a career that's more
than just the job they enter and we
think we have the responsibility to help
them to acquire the skills that are
going to be necessary as the world
changes when I look at the video of the
robots I think that seems like an
efficient quick way of doing something
which would eliminate the need for a
person to do it well
we've deployed about 200,000 robots at
the same time we've added three hundred
thousand people so what's happened is
we've added more things that require
more human work and judgment in certain
areas but we can add robots to do some
things that humans would just have to
repeat over and over again as technology
races forward the number of companies
investing in training their current
employees will climb from 54% in 2018 to
84% by next year that's according to a
manpower group study digital talent now
is not a luxury anymore it's something
that companies need just to survive
New York University business professor
ari Ginsberg says the so called
upskilling programs help companies
retain their employees and keep
recruiting costs down if you don't know
how to manage to technology and
incorporate it you can fall behind very
quickly as for Amazon drones may soon be
delivering your packages but the company
assures us humans are here to stay
finish this statement for me this is a
big deal because because it's going to
create more career opportunities for a
hundred thousand employees and we're
just getting started
Amazon may be right on time according to
a 2018 world economic jobs report by 22
- at least 54% of employees in every
industry will require significant
retraining and upskilling
due to artificial intelligence and other
automation technologies to meet future
workforce needs
David weren't there some concerns about
dangerous working conditions within
those warehouses what did the company
say about that a lot of concerns I asked
him about that he kind of dodged the
question he seemed to recognize what I
was talking about though here's what he
said
some people work miles in a warehouse a
day walk miles right these robots help
with something like that
he didn't address the question head-on
but he did say this Michelle if you want
to tour an Amazon warehouse we'll let
you come in and look at anything you
want because we stand by the safety
standards
that we uphold all right watch all those
robots moving around the warehouse I
have to say yeah it must be easy to
manage robots you know they never have
issues with child child care that ever
crying in a bathroom stop pick the
humanity out of it why don't you you
know start running his camera with the
robot right thank you very much